notamment après un week end marqué par
les mobilisations et les annonces du
premier ministre les actions des
grévistes se poursuivre
oui ils sont toujours présents sur le
terrain 40ème jour de grève et les
grévistes étaient donc sont donc
toujours rassemblés ici au dépôt de bus
de pantin en seine-saint-denis
bien déterminé ni les annonces de d'or
philippe annie l'appel du premier
ministre à terminer cette grève non
j'ai entendu ils sont toujours aussi
déterminés sur ce qu'ils dénoncent comme
une opération de communication à savoir
ce retrait provisoire de la pivot il
ils appellent eux pour leur part au
retrait total de cette réforme des
retraites je propose d'écouter une agent
ratp qu'on a interrogés tout à l'heure
quand je pense que le noyau à
du départ les gens qu'ils ont vraiment
et la grève avec conviction qu'ils ont
pris conscience de la gravité de la
situation sont aussi déterminé que moi
on a eu une réunion hier le mot d'or il
n'a pas changé et à l'est les troupes
sont toujours autant motivé et moi si je
dois faire la grève encore un mois je
t'avais pas longtemps à moi y a pas
d'histoire et ensuite même si le temps
bas ne tend pas c'est qu'effectivement
on n'a pas de salaire arrêter maintenant
ça serait ça n'aurait aucun sens donc
moi je suis déterminé et les annonces
faites me motive encore plus parce qu'on
voit bien que l'état n'est pas sera l
état se moque de nous donc sans le
retrait total on continuera vous l'aurez
compris la détermination des grévistes
est donc intacte ils ont pu compter ce
matin sur le soutien de parlementaires
de femmes parlementaires qui sont venus
à leur rencontre d'une part donc pour
leur apporter leur soutien en ce 40ème
jour de grève
d autre part pour mettre la lumière sur
l'impact
les retraites sur les femmes
particulièrement je vous propose
d'écouter deux élus c'est un micro de
stéphanie nous sommes non seulement dans
la rue depuis le 5 décembre mais que
nous sommes aussi sur leur lieu de
travail avec eux parce que nous aussi
les femmes nous sommes les où sont les
grandes perdantes de cette réforme est
là dans un monde de majoritairement
d'hommes
nous voulons
leur dire voilà ne vous découragez pas
c'est vrai edouard philippe
ce qu'il a présentée est une fumisterie
le soutien au mouvement est très fort
parce que la réforme prend en compte
l'ensemble de la carrière plutôt que les
25 meilleures années et qui sanctionne
les femmes qui ont des enfants qui
sanctionne les femmes qui touchent des
pensions de réversion est sur le terrain
ici particulièrement vous avez des
femmes qui sont mobilisés ces femmes qui
sont souvent en visibiliser d'un
mouvement social et qui pour autant
jouent un rôle déterminant et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui on a voulu être
présente en tant qu'élu femmes sur le
terrain pour porter cette voix qu'on
entend parfois peu dans le mouvement
social et qui pourtant jouent un rôle
déterminant
voilà donc pour les revendications des
grévistes et des élus qui sont venus à
leur rencontre
le dépôt de bus est toujours occupé donc
part à des grévistes des bus continuent
malgré tout de sortir de ce dépôt à
noter enfin que des actions font d'ores
et déjà prévues cette semaine des
actions de mobilisation pour continuer à
protester donc contre cette réforme des
retraites